si presenta un problema grave con la
válvula aórtica en el corazón y no puede
ser sometido a una cirugía a corazón
abierto el médico puede recomendarle una
implantación de válvula aórtica
transcatéter
y la válvula aórtica es una de las
cuatro válvulas del corazón
se encuentra entre el ventrículo
izquierdo o cámara inferior izquierda y
el vaso sanguíneo grande que suministra
sangre rica en oxígeno al cuerpo
denominado aorta cuando el ventrículo
izquierdo se contrae en cada latido del
corazón empuja la sangre a través de las
tres barbas flexibles con forma de taza
que conforman la válvula aórtica
cuando el ventrículo izquierdo se relaja
la válvula aórtica se cierra para evitar
que la sangre fluya hacia el ventrículo
izquierdo
cuando uno envejece la válvula aórtica
puede desarrollar depósitos de calcio
que provocan que estas balbás sean más
gruesas y menos flexibles en esta
condición es posible que las valvas no
se abran por completo
esta condición denominada estenosis de
válvula aórtica calcificada crea una
apertura estrecha que reduce la cantidad
de sangre que fluye hacia la aorta y
hacia el cuerpo la apertura estrecha de
la válvula deforma el corazón debido a
que debe bombear más fuerte para llevar
la sangre rica en oxígeno al cuerpo
al comienzo del procedimiento el médico
realizará una pequeña incisión en la
ingle
después de crear una apertura en un vaso
sanguíneo denominado arteria femoral
el médico insertará un tubo flexible
denominado vaina introductora
a través de la vaina el médico insertará
un alambre guía flexible en la arteria
femoral
este alambre guía pasará a través de la
arteria femoral hasta la aorta
luego el alambre guía será empujado a
través de la apertura en la válvula
aórtica y hacia adentro del ventrículo
izquierdo
el médico usará el alambre guía para
pasar un tubo flexible denominado
catéter a través de la válvula aórtica
se inflará un globo en la punta del
catéter para ensanchar la apertura en la
válvula aórtica y empujar las valvas de
la válvula hacia los costados después de
desinflar el globo
el médico retirará el catéter
la válvula de reemplazo consiste de una
válvula de tejidos rodeada de una malla
de alambre denominada stent se
comprimirá la válvula de reemplazo se la
colocará en la punta de otro catéter
este catéter será introducido a través
de la válvula aórtica
cuando el catéter llega a la apertura en
la válvula aórtica
el cirujano inflar a un globo debajo de
la válvula de reemplazo para expandir
tanto la válvula como el stent
después de colocar la nueva válvula
aórtica el cirujano desinflar a el globo
el stent sostiene la válvula de
reemplazo y la mantiene fija en su lugar
luego se retirará en el catéter y el
alambre guía
al final del procedimiento se retirará
la vaina introductora de la ingle
se cerrará la incisión en la piel con
puntos
tendrá otra incisión en el otro lado de
la ingle a través de la cual se
insertaron los instrumentos para
monitorear el corazón durante el
procedimiento esta incisión en la piel
se cerrará del mismo modo